البدايه من صحيفه لوموند التي سلطت الضوء
على الكارثه الانسانيه المستمره في غزه
رغم مرور شهر من اعتماد مجلس الامن التابع
للامم المتحده قرارا ينص على ايصال
مساعدات واسعه النطاق الى القطاع وتنقل
الصحيفه عن يانس لايرك المتحدث باسم مكتب
تنسيق الشؤون الانسانيه في الامم المتحده
ان الوصول الى شمال غزه وهو طقه الاكثر
حرمانا اليوم يرفض بشكل متكرر من قبل
السلطات
الاسرائيليه نقلت صحيفتها ارتس عن مصادر
وصفتها بالمطل ان نتنياهو قال لعائلات
الرهائن ان اسرائيل مستعده لتقديم تنازلات
من اجل صفقه جديده واضافت ان نتنياهو
مستعد على ما يبدو ليكون اكثر مرونه بشان
عدد وهويه السجناء الفلسطينيين الذين سيتم
اطلاق سرحهم واشارت الصحيفه الى ان
اسرائيل لا تخطط حاليا لاستعاده الرهائن
من خلال عمل عسكري اذ قال نتنياهو ان
اسرائيل لن تكون قادره على اعلان وقف
القتال كجزء من الاتفاق كما طالبت
حماس تحدثت صحيفه جيروزالم بوست عن مخاوف
من ان تؤدي حرب طويله الامد ربما طوال
العام الجاري الى سلسله من التكاليف
المؤلمه بما في ذلك مقتل الرهائن ومئات
جنود وتوجيه ضربه قاضيه للاقتصاد وتدمير
مكانه اسرائيل في العالم اضافه الى كارثه
استراتيجيه تتمثل في الصراع مع اداره
بايدن وهو ما سيكون كارثيا من الناحيه
الاستراتيجيه حسب الصحيفه قال موقع
بلومبيرج ان الحرب بين اسرائيل وحماس حسب
تعبيره اوقفت التقدم فيما يعرف بالممر
الاقتصادي بين الهند والشرق الاوسط
واوروبا وهو المشروع الاكثر طموحا في
العالم الذي روجت له واشنطن وحلفاؤها
الرئيسيون العام الماضي ويتصور بناء خطوط
سكك حديديه جديده عبر شبه الجزيره العربيه
واشار الموقع الى ان المشروع في حاله
تجميد فعليا مع تعطيل هجمات الحوثيين
للشحن البحري في البحر الاحمر وانتشار
الاضطرابات في جميع انحاء المنطقه بدوره
صرح كاميرون بوي رئيس شركه الشحن العملاقه
باج لويد لصحيفه التليغراف ان على العالم
ان يستعد لموجه ثانيه من الاضطرابات
التجاريه الناجمه عن ازمه البحر الاحمر
حتى بعد حل الصراع واضاف ان التاخيرات قد
تستمر لعده اشهر حتى بعد توقف هجمات
الحوثيين على السفن التي تمر عبر مضيق باب
المندب وهذه احدث علامه على ان الازمه
يمكن ان تبقي التضخم مرتفعا لفتره اطول مع
تسرب تكاليف الشحن المرتفعه الى الاقتصاد
العالمي